We wondered when it would happen and it's
happening next week.
Public hearings in Donald Trump's impeachment
inquiry are scheduled to start on Wednesday
now.
There will be three witnesses to start.
They will be William Taylor, the top us Envoy
to Ukraine, George Kent, a top state department
official and Marie over NAWIC, the former
ambassador to the Ukraine who says she was
told you'd better start tweeting positive
things about Donald Trump or you might lose
your job.
We heard from the chair of the house intelligence
committee, democratic Congressman Adam Schiff
who tweeted yesterday quote next week the
house intelligence committee will hold its
first open hearings as part of the impeachment
inquiry on Wednesday November 13th we will
hear from William Taylor and George Kent on
Friday, November 15th we will hear from Marie
Yoav a NAWIC more to come.
So the immediate question in general for this
impeachment inquiry is are the witnesses actually
going to show up?
Now these three have already spoken privately
with investigators and there's every indication
they are going to be there.
The real question is more about the other
witnesses that may be called and whether they
will be allowed to get away with simply ignoring
requests for documents, requests to appear
and potential subpoenas.
So far they have shown that they are going
to try to avoid those and it's going to be
a question of whether Democrats try and or
are able to enforce those subpoenas that will
presumably subsequently be handed out.
Now the format of these hearings is very interesting
and it's one of the most important elements
of all of this.
If you've seen congressional hearings before,
you're probably used to, you know, you've
got 16 lawmakers who get five minutes each
with the witness and it leads to very little
substance.
If you've got a lawmaker who doesn't want
to actually ask tough questions, they can
fill a Buster for four and a half of their
five minutes and then ask some dumb softball
question at the end.
Like you would never do anything immoral,
would you mr witness?
No, I wouldn't.
That's what I thought.
Thank you.
So that's one side.
The lawmakers who actually want to do the
work of questioning.
The witnesses run out of time when all they
have is five, especially when the witnesses
can come prepared with techniques to not have
to answer questions and to consume a whole
bunch of time.
That is not how these impeachment care hearings
are going to go.
Starting next week.
The rules that were approved last week allow
Democrats and Republicans on the committee
to number one designate the questioning to
train staff.
They can sort of delegate and say, I'm not
going to do the questioning.
We're bringing in somebody who is actually
more specialized in this area, which will
be great, but more importantly, they will
get up to 45 minutes at a time of 45 minutes
at a time.
Makes it much more difficult to avoid answering
questions than five minutes allows witnesses
to do so.
That's going to be a very good thing.
There's not that much more to say about the
hearings specifically until we get to them
other than this is why voting matters.
The 2018 midterms Democrats take over the
house.
Okay, it's the house fine.
We still can't get major legislation through
because there's a Republican Senate.
Trump still controls the white house and could
veto anything that we get through a Republican
Senate.
Who cares?
Well, we only have an impeachment inquiry
right now because Democrats won the 2018 midterms
and now control the house and the house intelligence
committee.
If that impeachment inquiry is going to damage
Donald Trump and destroy his reelection chances
in 2020 which it may do, it may not, but it
may.
That's the goal.
Anyway, that will be because Democrats took
over control of the house in November of 22
in November of 2018 rather because many of
you got out and voted a formal impeachment
inquiry resolution, which we got last week.
It only passed the house because Democrats
won the house in the 2018 midterms.
This is why we vote now as far as Trump expect
him to lose it on Twitter.
Maybe he'll try to shut down government.
Maybe he'll bomb some country.
Who knows what he will do, but this is what
we've been waiting for.
Public impeachment hearings.
It's about to start.
We'll be watching.
Question for you.
I was thinking, does it make sense for us
to restream on our YouTube channel, the impeachment
hearings next week, they're going to be taking
place during the time of day where we are
typically preparing the daily show and producing
the daily show and editing the daily show.
So my ability to actually get in and comment
will be sporadic maybe around the production
of the show, but we could just run a live
stream on our channel.
It might bring in a bunch of people.
It's an interesting idea.
If you think it makes sense for us to do that,
uh, let me know.
And I mean, even if it just garnered like
5,000 concurrent live viewers, that would
still be really great for the channel, potentially.
But is there value in doing that?
If I can only get in and comment every once
in awhile, let me know what you think.
Uh, make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram for continued coverage of
the Donald Trump impeachment inquiry at David
Pakman show
on Instagram.
And please, while you're there, follow me
as well.
At
David dot.
Pathogens,